the gyro can experience Aubrey de Grey
who's a life extension specialist was
online podcast last week yeah and he
thinks that that's the future of
regenerative medicine is that they're
these advancements and stem-cell therapy
and medical technologies that they're
eventually going to hit some point where
they can sort of treat aging like it's a
disease instead of like it's an
inevitability right treating it like
it's a disease and actually reverse the
process holy [ __ ]
no thanks you gonna look like you're 12
years old you're gonna go so are 30 when
I was 12 you're gonna [ __ ] it up
you're gonna go so far you're gonna turn
to a little kid and your wife's go go I
just
I missed the old Santino I got so much
energy in a week yeah come on [ __ ] you
all day okay he's gonna hang out with my
friends I'm gonna [ __ ] you 13 times
imagine if we get we [ __ ] up and you do
stem-cell therapy but it goes too far
and you're like Benjamin buttons here's
the other way all look like kids you go
back to a kid you [ __ ] up it imagines
they [ __ ] it up imagine if like they
go okay we've never seen this before
Andrew um how tall are you how tall are
you like six six months and sometimes
like six one like you're 511 like what
and you look like you're 14 what what
yeah what do you what do you say I don't
think there's anything to worry about
because I think at the very least like
the worst thing is you'll get to go 14
15 16 17 18 19 again good to do it all
over again it's like you're a 14 year
old with all the knowledge and I don't
think you're gonna get any younger you
like what do mean you don't think you
know we don't know yet we're not sure
and then you come back in four months
later and you're smaller still I'm nine
now you're nine years old
you're losing like a year every six
months I'm nine I'm holding in my poop
my anxiety is out of high I'm not
imagining it they can reverse the aging
process what if they [ __ ] it up and turn
you into a baby and you got all this
money and then they like just signing
over your will when you're two and your
face.you families like he can't
understand what signing a girl I'm too
but I'm 50 how'd you look like you - you
got the pen and everything you
ready to write [ __ ] down mr. baby baby
the family's like there's no [ __ ] way
you cannot let him sign this he's too
sick nobody I'm not but he can't talk
his arms are flailing around like a baby
you have to sign everything off by the
time you can't talk anymore cuz it's
gonna get to a point in time we're just
gonna make goo-goo noises like trapped a
55 year old man trapped in the baby do
you die then day you just crawl right
back at your mom's [ __ ] that's who
she's gotta be around he's gotta be
around to see a baby to this house this
were they gonna just put her on the same
program bring her back sometimes she's
20 okay great climb right back in it was
a reverse button you said like use it at
the right time by the time you're 80 and
just go back down the time you're six
and then hit it again yeah yeah good
once go back to just live forever I
don't want to learn out forever but like
just double instead of going on and they
idiot but then you'd go breakfast I
would you one more time B imagine being
slowly reverse imagine me in ten years
old today like if you just had to go
back to school at ten and kids be trying
to bully you and say stupid [ __ ] do you
imagine what you would do to those kids
murder
well I wouldn't beat him up but I'm just
just talking to them oh you could suck a
good mind [ __ ] electric just try to
be mean to you yeah I got Bobby you try
and be meaning me Bobby yeah what's the
matter Bob I know about you I know about
your father's addiction and the fact
that your problems with the neighbor
wait what there's a great there's a
great scene there's a phenomenal scene
in a show called pen15 this these girls
are like my age but they play teenagers
on the show all right it's cool it's
great it's really funny but there was a
funny scene when she gets pep talk into
talking [ __ ] during a fight and and
she's like her friend is that call him
an aardvark dick and she's like okay
what else and she's like just use any
ammunition you have against him right
and he's bullying the girl and she's
like whatever aardvark dick and
everyone's laughing and then she goes
yeah and that's why your dad died and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] that's me it's
such a good seed and she's she thinks
she's like [ __ ] it's like everyone's
cheering her on she says his dad died
crying yeah if you had if you had the
intellectual capacity to just shut down
like I mean it's it's usually break word
to you break them
[Applause]